I really love doing this work and I
think it's very special it's very moving
to me Patrick Dempsey Hollywood star and
hero he opened the Dempsey Center in his
hometown of Lewiston Maine in 2008 a
place where cancer patients can receive
free treatments like meditation yoga
counseling and nutrition classes
Patrick invited eg inside for an
exclusive dwarf this is probably Amanda
Dempsey it's it's in memory of my mother
and it's just a place for people to come
and have an accent play the actor was
inspired by his mom's 17-year battle
with ovarian cancer she passed away in
2014
how did her journey inspire you to
create this losing my mother the cancer
I think if you look at it the big
picture her legacy and what she's
inspired because of her battle with
cancer and ultimately her her losing
that fight is has made a profound
positive impact on the community and and
that's special I try to get back once a
month if I can to come to the center
there's so much work to be done so much
what has been done and I just have the
spirit of being here this is real life
and you know when you encounter someone
who's just been recently diagnosed and
they step off
the elevator and they come here for the
first time that's a profound moment when
Patrick visits he sits in on counseling
sessions is it distracting at all for
people I think initially but I think
where they're at emotionally that we get
past it very quickly I think people
would like that I'm here I like being
here and I learn a lot every time I come
in and I have an encounter with how
emotional is it for you to come back to
your hometown oh it's always very
emotional for me to come back here
because there's so much emotion
especially on challenge weekend that be
the annual Dempsey challenge which
raised over 1 million dollars this year
my mother loved walking that was her
meditation and not everybody can afford
a bike not everybody wants to be on a
bike so we want to make sure that it was
important to keep people active you feel
much better when you're physically
active yeah so the walk is that and it's
a nice experience to be walking and then
there's the run and there's the bike
does your family participate yeah they
just got in late last night okay you
know from California had a good school
yesterday but they're here they look
forward to it every year Patrick and his
wife of 19 years are parents to three
kids what do you hope that this Center
teaches your kids about getting back
that's the most important thing about
and the center has also taught him about
giving back if we could live like this
every day as it as a as communities and
as a world the rule would be much better
place and it's it's it's unfortunate
that when you're having to take a look
at their mortality and that you've been
diagnosed with something that may not
have a positive outcome that you're
forced to look at that
you know in a way so it changes your
perspective from the biggest lesson for
me is to just stop and be there with
that person and listen and that's
sometimes the hardest and the easiest
thing you can do and certainly the
platform of being a celebrity or being
an actor that's known around the world
how profoundly grateful I am for the
experience of gray's that allowed that
to happen that we get people that we
normally wouldn't
[Music]